it was always my father's dream to move  to California that we can start a whole  new life a new beginning  [Music]  we are going to be surrounded by beauty  so make this her home and fill it with  memory right now Wow mom you like Peter  Pan give the face you deserve after 30  you're beautiful and when the time comes  I know plenty of doctors I'll have a  cheeseburger and fries have a fantastic  metabolism really like surfing a lot I  really like you I have another chance to  be happy now  something happened unless one I mean  I've fallen in love are you serious  [Music]  I don't want you going out you're the  man of the house now  moms really elitism she she's just alone  here  [Music]  do you love dad yeah I don't  Maureen hutch you're alive anyway what  do you go right in front of your friends  not away  we can be a family again  find someone who loves you for who you  are on the inside  [Music]  we're gonna be happy here yeah  well I'm happy you're already  you